back on may 18th the official hogwarts
legacy youtube account dropped a brand
new video out of nowhere by the way
totally unexpected perhaps even more
unexpected though it was a 20-minute
asmr video that's right asmr showing off
eight different scenes and plenty of
intricate little details they knew that
we fans would be searching for now
there's all sorts of little details
hidden in this video we're gonna talk
about some of them today but there's
also one very big thing that i think
this whole entire video proves and in
addition to the one big thing i think
this video proves there are also some
hints to possible gameplay mechanics
that we're going to see in hogwarts
legacy as well and to me those are the
most exciting you know we went so long
without getting any information on this
game and since the big reveal at the
sony state of play where they showed
more than 14 minutes of gameplay footage
we've gotten a steady stream of
information not a lot but a slow and
steady stream of information with new
stuff hitting each week now at the time
of me recording this video we actually
just got the information about the
official game guide that's going to be
published by scholastic personally i'm
not much of a game guides guy myself i
kind of like to explore and figure out
things on my own but the amazon page for
it is live if you want to pre-order i'll
put a link down in the description below
it looks like it's going to be around
176 pages listed publication date of
december 31st 2022 and as i've told
several people already relating to other
things on amazon don't put any stock in
that december 31st date that is strictly
a placeholder date highly unlikely that
the game or this guide will even release
on that day now it also says that an
official cover is coming soon we don't
have that yet but rest assured once we
do we'll have a video up about that as
well unless it's just the game box art
and in that case it probably wouldn't be
that big of a deal then again i don't
think we even know the official box art
yet we have a pretty good idea of what
we've seen on amazon and best buy and
places like that but i don't know that
they've officially said yes this is the
box art but we'll find out hopefully
soon enough as for this asmr video
though the one thing that it really
proves to me and it's something i've
talked about time and time again but
it's the fact that avalanche is really
understanding their audience here they
really understand this world they really
understand what we as fans are looking
for and the fact that they gave us a 20
minute now it's only eight scenes but a
20 minute video just allowing us to kind
of be and exist in that world to chill
out for a bit to me really shows that
they understand what we want out of this
game now this is not saying the game is
going to be great amazing or epic or
anything like that but it is saying that
the folks at avalanche clearly
understand what they're dealing with
here all right so now let's get into
some of those little details throughout
the video if you haven't seen it yet i'd
be surprised if you haven't but if you
haven't it's called hogwarts legacy a
rainy spring night asmr 4k video and
there's going to be eight different
scenes that you can watch and it's
raining throughout so there's no music
it's all sounds of nature the sounds of
rain sounds of lightning you get some
bug sounds no music just a sort of
natural ambience of the world around you
again a rainy spring night so the fact
that they specifically call it a spring
night i think also speaks to the fact
that seasons are going to be in this
game we had that confirmed in that 14
plus minute gameplay reveal that we
already talked about but now this begs
the question are we gonna get more right
i mean we're in the heat of summer right
now perhaps they'll give us a summer one
and then maybe a winter one as well
leading up to the release of the game
remains to be seen so this first little
shot that we have right here you can see
hogwarts castle this is an area that we
are definitely familiar with we've seen
this in the trailer you also have the
owlery over here on the right side and
then kind of just below it here you have
the game keepers hut and as this scene
slowly pans to the left you'll
eventually be able to make out the
fountain on the left side over here as
well and the fountain includes some nice
little details like the heads of the
hogwarts mascot pretty sure there's a
boar right here and then you have a
snake over here so i'm assuming on the
other side we're gonna have a lion and a
badger and an eagle as well now shifting
into the next scene here we have another
shot just outside of hogwarts and i'm
not sure of the specific area of this if
you guys know let me know in the
comments below i'm just going to call it
a courtyard with a beast statue and
pretty sure this is an occamy statue
right here hopefully i'm pronouncing
that right it's o-c-c-a-m-y
and we know about these creatures from
fantastic beasts they have a serpentine
appearance and they also have the
ability to grow or shrink to fit the
available space around them so in
virtually everything we have seen so far
about this game guys the level of detail
the intricate little nods to the series
that they are including throughout this
whole entire world it seems but in this
case the castle the outside of the
castle is just incredible like i was
saying there's a lot of stuff in this
video but the biggest thing i take away
is just how much avalanche truly gets
the property that they're working with
here it's exciting to see all right now
we're going to shift gears a little bit
to another area of hogwarts here and
from this shot we can see the herbology
greenhouse just here on the left side
also have some flowers here and kind of
the front area other than that though
not a lot going on in this scene here
now the next one has what i think is one
of the most interesting pieces in any of
these scenes that we see and it is this
gold plate right here with a symbol that
we have seen in a number of different
locations i think most fans are kind of
referring to this as a phase of the moon
symbol i know one spot just off the top
of my head where we see a symbol like
this is in the great hall on that
stained glass window just behind the
teachers when we get that first shot of
zooming into hogwarts we see a symbol
that looks very similar to this now in
this next scene we get a shot of
hogsmeade so we move away from hogwarts
castle we get a shot of hogsmeade and
this one has probably the most
information by far there's a lot going
on in this scene also a watering can
that is watering flowers in the rain
which i found pretty funny as hilarious
as it seems to be that they are getting
watered in the rain i do love that they
just keep showing off these little
details of magic kind of showing itself
within the world that's not like active
magic i remember this was a big deal
with the second harry potter movie
chamber of secrets when they showed the
burrow for the first time they talked
about how they really wanted it to feel
alive remember you have in the kitchen
mrs weasley's dishes they're kind of
just cleaning themselves with a little
magical charm when harry arrives at the
borough so he's kind of taking it all in
same thing in prisoner of azkaban they
made sure to have a nod to just this
magical world that's going on around
them even without what i would call like
active magic and that's what we see here
we saw it in the big trailer as well so
over on the right we get yet another
quidditch hint quality quidditch
supplies very clearly that is what we
have here still do not have quidditch
confirmed as being in the game although
we have seen so many hints and i think
we can pretty safely say even if we
don't play quidditch quidditch is still
going to be part of this world and i can
already hear some of you saying well
really if they're gonna do that how can
they not let us play quidditch i don't
know i think that remains to be seen
we'll just have to keep an eye out for
that and see if we get official word as
to whether or not quidditch is actually
playable and then we shift over here to
the middle where we have the three
broomsticks the iconic pub and inn that
is featured throughout the series you
can actually eat there at universal
studios florida it's amazing it's
incredible yes they have butterbeer so
clearly this is an iconic spot that they
absolutely had to have in the game so
it's nice to see it here i think it
looks great now there's been a lot of
talk about ollivanders anytime i bring
up ollivander's people say of course
diagon alley is in the game it's got all
the vendors well this is the hogsmeade
branch of ollivanders and you can see
the ol right here on the side of this
building here so this is the
ollivander's location that we have seen
in the trailer we have not seen any sign
of diagon alley in any trailer other
than gringotts but given some of the
little hints and details that we saw in
that big trailer it's very possible that
we could travel to grangott's another
way maybe through one of those portals
that the main character and professor
fig seem to be opening then as we keep
moving left we also have the sign
pointing out zonkos as well as a sign
here on the left no doubt leading to the
hog's head now i wanna know what you
guys think this spot is right here i
have some guesses but i'm curious to see
what you all think i'm gonna zoom in
here to give you an even better view we
can't quite make it out and before we
leave the scene we have to go over to
one of the gameplay element hints that i
teased in the opening of the video and
that is if you look over here at the
right on the door for quality quidditch
supplies we have what looks to be a
padlock of some sort now a padlock alone
wouldn't be that big of a deal right i
mean clearly it's evening clearly the
shops are closed they've locked up for
the night no big deal however there are
a couple of times in this scene as the
asmr video continues to play in fact if
you want to see one exactly you can stop
it right around 10 39 now this is on the
official hogwarts legacy video if you
stop it at 10 39 i'll show you right
here in this video as well what happens
but you'll see this little kind of
bluish purple gleam that goes across the
lock and to me this clearly is
indicating something that the player can
interact with most likely a location
where we can use alohomora to unlock so
not only does it give us a gameplay hint
in terms of being able to use aloha more
to unlock things it also leads me to
believe that perhaps we'll even be able
to sneak around at night go into
hogsmeade when all the shops are closed
and perhaps even sneak into various
shops is it just quality quidditch
supplies or will we be able to sneak
into hogsmeade as well will you be able
to sneak into any shop because that
would be absolutely insane if you could
sneak into any shop or perhaps there's a
very specific mission where we have to
get into quality quidditch supplies and
this lock that we see here is what we
have to unlock using alhamora but more
on that shimmering light in just a
moment because when we shift over to the
next scene here you'll see madame
puttyfoot's tea shop right here on the
left side so again we're still in
hogsmeade the tea shop featured
prominently here then if you look
straight back here you'll see a shop
with the initials a g r almost certainly
this is glad rex where you can get
various wizard clothing and then you
can't see it at the start of this scene
but as it sort of pans over to the right
throughout you'll eventually be able to
make out the pogsme post office which is
just behind the tea shop also there's a
moment in this scene where you can see
an owl just fly right over and while not
as overt as the lock on the door i also
think this hints to some possible
gameplay mechanics now this one it could
just be entirely possible that it's part
of the living breathing world we're
gonna see owls flying around and
carrying letters but book readers will
know it was a really big deal in
prisoner of azkaban and then goblet of
fire this idea of letters possibly being
intercepted especially when harry's
trying to stay in touch with sirius and
then if you got the ministry involved we
know there's a potential goblin
rebellion right now so it's very
possible that we could be seeing some of
these letters getting intercepted by
either ministry officials or again maybe
it even ties into one of our missions
maybe we have to make sure that one of
our letters doesn't get intercepted or
if you're going to be on that dark side
maybe you are doing the intercepting
maybe you actually have to intercept the
letter all of these are interesting
possibilities and before we go we can't
forget about hingis of woodcroft over
here on the right side the founder of
hogsmeade village and then yet another
hint at possible gameplay with this
barrel right here we can see sort of a
little white glow a little white shimmer
similar to the one we saw with the lock
earlier however this one is on the
barrel and honestly i would probably say
we could even go ahead and outright
confirm that this will be an
interactable object like we see in the
trailer with our character actually
using barrels in battle now shifting
over to the next scene here i said we'd
talk more about that little blue glimmer
and i think we see another little blue
light here in this scene although this
one is much harder to make out i'll show
it to you here if you want to watch on
the official hogwarts legacy video it's
around 15 39 and then another one around
15 51 but it's the moment right there
and you can see this one seems a little
bit lower to the ground but then again
you kind of got an odd perspective here
because that building is pretty far off
so it very well could be a lock or it's
possibly just another interactable item
we don't really know the biggest
standout piece of this area right here
though is of course the hogs head over
here on the left an in and pub that of
course featured very prominently in the
harry potter series and then for the
very last section we get an outdoor
scene with a couple of little
interesting tidbits here first of all
i'm pretty intrigued by the fact that we
have a graveyard here we also have an
old house up here on the left and then a
building here i guess you could say a
sign most likely a building just behind
it called the magic meep which is a
magical green grocer shop now if you
look at the harry potter wiki it says
this is located in hogsmeade so i assume
this is very close to hogsmeade here and
perhaps we're just looking at it from
kind of a different perspective maybe
directly behind the camera here so sort
of behind our first person perspective
perhaps that's the direction of
hogsmeade itself and the other big one
that stands out to me here is this over
here on the right i mean is this a cage
for those of you who have followed the
channel for a while you know i've had a
theory for quite some time that magical
creatures and their overall treatment
within the wizarding world is going to
feature prominently in this game goblin
rights are going to feature prominently
in this game at least in my opinion so
perhaps this is some sort of enclosure
that someone is going to use at some
point in this game involving the magical
creatures i don't know if they're trying
to help them and get them out get them
safe or if they're trying to capture
them for their own purposes that remains
to be seen now speaking of the hogwarts
legacy story i have a full breakdown of
all the lord everything we know so far
about the story i'll include it here on
the right side of your screen as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon